TO YOU BY TOYOTA.  THE FIRST SHT
OF THE GAME.
GIVE THE H H GOES TOP SHELF.
PUCW
MOMENTARILY.
GOOD SAVE  A 6-5-4 FROM A TOUGH.
BUT IT WENT RIGHT TO THE SHARK
FORWARD AND THE BUT I THINK RIG,
IT WENT OFF A  GOT
TERMS OF
GOALS AGAINST
AND THEN JONES THROWS IT
TRYING TO MOVE AHEADIT'S MATCHE
KANE LOOKING TO MAKETO JONES TH
OVER TO STROME.
HE'S GOT A WIDE OPEN NET.
NO
REGULA.
ANOTHER TAKE AWAY.
HE LETS TIME.
HE AIRMAILS IT.
IT COMES BACK IN THE CHANCE OF
HAD HIMSELF A REALLY STRONG
TO GO BACK TO KANE.
THE PASS WAS HIT.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S THE PC
THING TO SAY. LOOSE.
JUST ALMOS
WAS A MATTER
NOBODY WIL COUTURE WITH HIM.
GOT IT UP OFF  INTO THE
MIDDLE.
HERE'S THE SHOT.
AND D
IN THE DRIVER'S SEAT. K INTO